let's talk a little bit more about how
the internet works we've already
established that every device and every
other thing along the way in the
Internet has its own IP address now
these IP addresses are assigned based on
location using these IP addresses your
device can talk to your modem which you
probably have in your home then to a
router which is set up by your web
service the router would go to the
domain name server this is still just
sending your request
now that domain name server would send
back the information that was asked for
and it would go right back to your
device now you might think this is
pretty fallible if one of these steps
goes out the whole process is done but
really there's so many more connections
with so many routers and so many servers
is that if one huge chunk of the
internet goes out that still won't
really affect the functionality of
anything else there are just infinite
connections it's amazing now what I want
you to take away from this video is that
your device since it has its own IP
address can send out a request for
information that information is sent
back to your device the way it gets to
your device is because of the IP address
and the way it gets there is through all
the lines of the modems and routers and
servers that make up the Internet now
that explanation of the Internet is
really really basic if you're interested
in more check out some of these links so
we're providing for some more
information